[Applaus]
das meiner frau und mir war machen wir
bis jetzt sind wir bereit das ist okay
das ist nicht schlecht so gefälscht
immer verwehrt hochdruck aber der rest
ist dann alles was gut die zehn musiker
sport brandwache wirtschaft also alles
die vier operationen einfach und der
linke sieht sondern einen schnitt machen
und 84 cm großer schnitt einfach wie man
diese verbrauchen wir mal gesehen haben
naja bin 320 gb seien auch selbst einige
schweine oder autofahrer aber natürlich
nur aus ist die operation nicht
vollständig gelingt der kann ja eine
selbständig klappen soll
aber dafür hat es probiert wenn schon
als untauglich glück unglück traf aber
meistens auf sehr gut tun
also machen wir dann nicht zu große
gedanken
[Musik]
sven ist 14 jahre alt seit seinem
siebten lebensjahr leidet er an
epilepsie eine der häufigsten
neurologischen erkrankungen
epileptische anfälle sind kurzzeitige
funktionsstörungen des gehirns dabei
kommt es zu spontanen entladungen von
nervenzellen
die vielen anfälle beeinflussen svens
leben massiv
doch es gibt einen ausweg dem hoffnung
auf ein neues leben bieten kann
[Musik]
der einstieg staa v ich war gerade drei
sterne academicus das los ist das wenig
wie die quasi live webinar lag sie mit
einem von nach sprachverstehen motto
nitro einem treten da bestimmt nicht am
boden
[Musik]
afrika und ist selber gemerkt dass sie
das für mehr aus ist still standen
einfach es geht
hätten wir das foto gemacht verrät
sekunde
nazareth dpa fahrräder hat probiert es
nicht gelungen
und was ist jetzt los
[Musik]
wir sind es gab klare und die deswegen
da sich nicht dass sogar künftig soviel
ihre blaue lippen
sagen wir's mal mit dem wechsel fiel
eine stange gefahren des maxity elektro
auch im schnitt lagen
[Musik]
gerade taktisch auf philipp sie kann
unterschiedliche ursachen haben eine
erblich bedingte veranlagung
stoffwechselstörungen entzündungen
traumata oder hirntumore in der schweiz
sind etwa 80.000 menschen von epilepsie
betroffen
svens anfälle treten vor allem am abend
auf häufig auch nachts schnarcht oder
schafe die erste tv hat meistens also
ich könnte einfach werden aber nur sie
macht sprach klar dass er gut wird oder
geht dafür sowie die sache vorsichtig
angefangen mit englisch aufhören mit 25
oder irgendwie ist nicht irgendein ich
brauche noch hängen im stück zwei
minuten
wenn jetzt aber durch magath vk
die nacht ist jetzt schnell die rückgang
so dass sie einfacher mit nacht vor
augen und richtig geschlafen
für 2008 erwartet
olaf nicht richtig prima wieder lauter
er ist körperlich total ausgeliefert und
ist erstens nicht mehr stören
das ist so wie wenn nicht sogar mit der
stimmt das nicht
sind sie das spricht was auch jeder
hingehen und sagen das ist ja nicht
versiegt oder halo das kleid nicht die
verantwortung übernahm mit dem auch
schlimme ab ob das was sie
also kam vorschlägen ist eine box mit
masken reden und nochmals zu machen
das glück auf seiner geburt kann
jugendlichen verbessern
[Musik]
ja das wenig cellulite sozialkontakte
ist sehr zurückhaltend gesehen hat es
geregnet ihre sprache als größte defizit
karte ein geschlossenes gelände ruf
blüht also deshalb besonders aufgefallen
ist eine stunde kostet mich sehr gut
kommen
[Musik]
mit glücklichem isny erschweren aufbau
uhr live konzert und physisch
gesamtzweiter der dritten woche in der
unterrichtung sowie komischen verfassung
der frage was ist mit dem moment ist es
so wie ist auch liza mixa produkt für
jeden platz ist also jetzt an bord
erhofften sieg doch jetzt da im
schafspelz steht erstmals auch mit genau
jene realisiert das gesetz ganz
komisches aber der rückschlag bei seiner
mission auf außen liga rund zwei drittel
der an epilepsie erkrankten menschen
können mit medikamenten erfolgreich
behandelt werden oft gestaltet sich die
suche nach einem wirksamen medikament
jedoch schwierig mit medikamenten
stellen was relativ lange gut gegangen
weil mit dem wachstum mit sattel
pubertät frauen
die dav massiv zugenommen so mit 70
punkten die gruppe 5 auf dem medikament
nimmt oder neue songs wie sie das zweite
wort sage immer wieder bis zum glück
nicht fertig machen das wieder besser
berlin jackson war schon einmal ein
dafür muss mit regen in der nacht pro
monat sagt jetzt mal 30 uhr noch am
anfang und es hat einfach mit sven
essanfälle können mit medikamenten nicht
verhindert werden
die appy klinik in zürich bietet in
diesen schwierigen fällen hilfe an
[Musik]
jede nacht noch an fälle also ganz
selten mal ein zwei nächte ohne anfälle
und dann ist oft auch zwei brachten die
2 da hat man schon mal bisher
ausführlicher über die operation
gesprochen hast du da noch mal drüber
nachgedacht auch mit deinen eltern
zusammen mehr stimmen zur kooperation
hat bin ich eigentlich hoffte positiver
sieht xii wenn einmal die risiken
einfach die durch die operation da sind
und das andere sind die risiken die
durch den ort an dem er operiert bedingt
sind da müssen wir genau hingucken was
sind dafür funktionen war es eine
komplikation wäre die ganz ganz selten
ist aber theoretisch möglich ist ist ja
dass es den kleinen schlaganfall macht
kann vorübergehend sein aber wenn gefäß
praktisch so nicht richtig verletzt
würde
dann können dann praktisch auch wie eine
lähmung ein schlaganfall zurückbleiben
der kunstvolle körperliche schrank krieg
ja jetzt sollte kam
also wird somit gar nix machen die
epilepsie
die hat auch ein risiko und die hat auch
ein risiko für für die
gedächtnisfunktionen also wenn wenn das
weiter so bleibt mit mit den vielen
anfällen
dann wird's irgendwann wird wird das
gedächtnis dann schlechter weil weil das
ja immer die anfälle immer sich in der
hirnregion abspielen
deshalb muss man auch dieses risiko
durch die operation etwas relativieren
da haben wir immer ein unmittelbares
risiko durch den eingriff während hier
diese epilepsie hat ja auch noch so sohn
langzeitrisiken das muss man halt mit
abwägen
wenn alles gut passt werden die chancen
von so einer operation in der regel 70
das mal anfallsfrei wird darüber machen
da sitze da oft mit der wirtschaft genau
wisst dass ich das geht nicht mehr
mitmacht bewerten
als ich das risiko
am see ich hoffe das gut geht
die epilepsie beeinflusst den alltag des
14 jährigen massiv
doch es gibt auch momente in denen sven
seine krankheit komplett vergessen kann
[Musik]
im sport mache das ist auch okay dem
club
weil es so eine sportmaschine das usa
sport
jedes jahr an schweizer meisterschaften
die nationalmannschaft wird kein
notorischer europameisterschaft
mitspieler so
[Musik]
svens anfällen im stark zu eine
operation erscheint der familien und die
beste chancen auf ein anfangs freies
leben zu sein
das wirkt wie ist es eine top karriere
mit einem fehler auf
aber das ist heute auch macht es dann
selber zu entscheiden
[Musik]
er macht ernst es war sogar die
operation wird einfach
unbedingt das ist
[Musik]
in der klinik wird sven von seiner
ärztin judith kröll über die
bevorstehende operation aufgeklärt
schön dass das arbeitsgas angekommen ja
gut da geht man in dein zimmer und
erklären wird dir was du morgen vorhaben
übermorgen morgen wird geübt und dann am
freitag wird es ernst
du weißt dass du deine epilepsie aus dem
linken schläfenlappen beginnt und dann
haben wir dir gesagt dass der linke
schläfenlappen ja auch wichtige aufgaben
hat guido auch jeden tag brauchen muss
hier habe ich noch mal aufgeschrieben
was wir in den bädern von deinem gehirn
sehen und wovon wir annehmen dass das
die ursache für deine epilepsie ist und
was wir machen möchten ist diese
fehlbildung die da ist entfernen
zwei drittel entfernung vom linken
schläfenlappen um ihre vorstellung da
ist eigentlich nicht so viel wenn die
förderzusage arminia operiert eigentlich
sogar froh das ist etwas getraut soll
bis zu machen was gemacht ich bin
einfach froh darüber dass es fertig ist
erwünscht die überweisung in die
neurochirurgische klinik möchte
kreuzchen zu machen ja gut dann machen
ich finde ich toll und dann
unterschreibst du da als patient
jetzt muss die mami noch unterschreiben
weil noch keine acht endlich lernen hast
was mitgebracht er
das ist nicht
sein müssen
[Musik]
an einem frühen morgen im august holen
adia und fabrice ihren sohn vom
kinderspital zürich ab darüber gerät
vorher
es ist eine ebenso gut vorbereitet
[Musik]
für den neurochirurgischen eingriff wird
sven ins universitätsspital zürich
bestellt
zum grillen und du musst mir versandes
du da und wieder aus
[Musik]
in der klinik wurde vorgängig präzise
abgeklärt welche hirnareale für die
epileptischen anfälle verantwortlich ist
und ob dieses beim operativen eingriff
kunde folgeschäden entfernt werden kann
schweizweit werden in unterschiedlichen
spitälern jährlich und 80 epilepsie
chirurgische eingriffe durchgeführt
am unispital zürich schon seit über 80
jahren
aufgrund der fortschritte in der
neurochirurgie sind sie sehr sicher
geworden und dennoch jeder eingriff am
hirn stellt ein risiko dar
der erfahrene chirurg mit klaus rein
mühen muss stets abwägen wie viel gewebe
er entfernt etwas zu viel und sven
könnte eine wichtige hirnfunktion
verlieren
[Musik]
das muster system in das system eine
ganze infrastruktur muss man sehr hoch
ist nicht krank
[Musik]
also für familie verzichten neu ist aber
wenn das volk bringt romero vor 5234
anschluss an die jungen bäume niestetal
gewonnen
das ist dass es trotz nach der ruhigen
nach dem rund vierstündigen eingriff
wird wenn noch unter vollnarkose zurück
ins kinderspital zürich verlegt
[Musik]
wie ich gesagt
red
[Musik]
richtung europa bewegt hat sich nicht
groß mit dem access merkt hätte doch
maxi das ist das ist beachtet das
wahrnimmt oder stocker kassiert ein
recht ist was sie genau vor augen wie
sehr freust du dich sehr dass die
operation jetzt ab chaotisch wie zwar
noch nicht ganz fitte also sicher gute
runde aber ich bin nicht ganz bitter
weil sie politisch wie es ist einfach
sehr verzögert haben das gefühl wenn man
mich fragt das geld verlangen also mein
beantwortet ist gar nicht was man fragt
das vertreibt also zwei tag spaghetti
kekse und salzstangen gesundheitlich sie
das aber zeitlich gut aus
eine rolle ich habe eigentlich clipinc
linienrichter verwandt ist
die sie aber formal ist das essen ist
das stimmt aprikosen und 2 naja ich seit
meinem alter gewisse irritation und das
[Musik]
die gäste standen wir da noch nie
was ist global zero gut gemacht ist sehr
sehr froh das aus für die spanier der
das ganze team fliegt die sarstedter
taste zum glück wird ihr ruf steffisburg
der benannten heute ein stadtteil rissen
mit torwart
[Musik]
ohne war
flug nicht aber andere aber verloren am
morgen bereits ausgebucht
nach der operation in einem messer sturm
das ist kaputt die wochenkarte also bis
jetzt
das medikament im hause unterstützen
nachdem ohne treffer mit medikamenten
zurückfahren geht etwas jahr und 1
machen
[Musik]
es vergehen zwei wochen in denen sich
sven von der operation erholt schon bald
wünscht er sich in einen möglichst
normalen alltag zurück nach um
eineinhalb monaten machte sich wieder
auf den weg in die schule
[Musik]
das glück aber nicht zwölf poster bremse
sage jetzt neue unternehmen jetzt daher
nachmittags im detail informiert wie man
das heck mit einem move starter und was
die da probiert helium wie hält es das
ganz klassisch der sturz ins flugzeug
also jederzeit natur bauen und so und es
ist ja praktisch nicht sichtbar
und jetzt kann ich entspannter hier aus
vorherigen die angst für mich die
unbewussten contitech der vhs konz mehr
geld für wirtschaft konzentriert
das ist groß
[Musik]
drei monate später wird sven von der
klinik erneut aufgeboten
1 mb soll zeigen wie die hirnstrukturen
postoperativ aussehen
svens ärztin die familie anschließend zu
einem gespräch ein
[Musik]
läuft alles gut
anfänglich hinweg und erste uni hockey
turnier hat auch funktioniert
erwartet war nämlich der letzte kontakt
mit der mama ob der da schon mitmachen
kann und wie läuft's in der schule schon
geld gut bist ganz zufrieden
der hass kopfschmerzen kann nachts gut
schlafen
dieser ohne angst erinnerst du dich als
hier
hier ist recht dreist legen
und da sieht man jetzt wurde linke
schläfenlappen ist und dann dass da
jetzt wieder in der höhle ist eine zyste
das gehirn wasser drin das ist das was
der doktor kreienbühl operiert hat
jungen wir hatten ja vermutet ist ohne
ausbau störung von der hirnrinde
man sieht also jetzt hier an dem rand
sieht man nichts mehr dass da was übrig
geblieben und so also sieht so aus was
man von dem bild erkennen kann dass das
vollständig entfernt worden ist und das
ist eigentlich das was uns alle
gewünscht also im september 19 sehen uns
wieder alles okay und sonst kriegst du
mail bis sechs jahre an der name ist
keine schmerzen zeigt es mir also so
sieht man sie kaum
wie sieht gut aus sehr schön was zuvor
in irgendwas nicht in ordnung ist höchst
aktiv versprochen
[Musik]
in den folgenden sechs monaten bleibt
wenn anfallsfrei die krankheit scheint
besiegt
doch dann an einem donnerstagmorgen nach
dem frühstück fällt wenn plötzlich hin
und erleidet einen großen anfall
er kämpft minutenlang am boden die
notfall medikamente helfen licht die
ambulanz muss gerufen werden
es ist der heftigste an fall den die
familie in all den jahren miterleben
musste
[Musik]
nach erneuter untersuchung wird ein früh
abgesetzt das medikament in niedriger
dosis wieder eingeführt zwei monate
später ist wieder ruhe eingekehrt
sven ist auch heute über ein jahr nach
der operation
[Musik]
die operation in der rückserie verändert
mich mal wieder durchschlafen wie ich
sie entspannt das ist weniger spannend
familie
entschädigt läufer da ich nichts machen
der match war madrid kommt der
kirchenspitze noch befinden sich noch
was er verspricht
das ist die story geben
[Musik]
es sieht auch so größtes anständigkeit
zurückgenommen auf seinem hänger kopf
hat man schon mal gestorben ist wird
nachts aufstehe abnehmen sich
zuversichtlich dass ein
busacca für sich das auto und die
entscheidung ist sehr aktiv ist
[Musik]
microstrom eigentlich gut dastehe zwei
selbständige familie zahl einfach ein
altes land
[Musik]